hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the 2017 edition of
the tata still masters it's richard
rapport versus magnus carlsen and uh as
this was played in 2017 i didn't really
follow events uh so religiously back
then i was mostly covering if it was a
nice game or two so i've missed this one
or maybe i've made it but i've made so
many videos that uh
i have no idea really uh but uh since um
our apart won the second leg of the
video grand prix that we've covered and
you guys requested uh to see more of his
games i thought that this one would be
just perfect
because it's well it's against magnus
carlsen and it's just uh well a
masterpiece of a game so it's uh not
only a great game but also it's very
important for the standings of the 2017
tata still masters uh so let's dive
straight into it and um even if i did
make a video on this game back in 2017 i
would still remake it uh because back
then my videos were at only 30 frames
per second as some of you guys know and
also i pronounced rihard's name uh
poorly so uh it's best to
even if i made a video i would remade it
uh so let's check it out rapport has the
white pieces and he starts with knight
to f3 goes for the red opening we have
d5 and now b3 going for the very strong
name so larson attack uh this is a game
from round eight of the tournament if
any of you guys are interested and
magnus goes for bishop to f5 and this is
a
very standard way of developing knight
to f6 is by far the most popular uh but
if you don't want to box your own light
square bishop in you're gonna first
develop it then you're gonna play e6
this is maybe
maybe looks a little bit greedy because
you are
taught that okay maybe black needs the
box in his light square bishop and then
as the game develops you will develop it
uh properly later on uh but here uh it's
developed right away and then we're
gonna play e6 bishop d7 or bishop c5 and
so on so here bishop to b2 uh putting
the bishop to this strong diagonal and
now e6 now we've put the bishop outside
of the cage and now we can develop our
dark square bishop without boxing any of
our pieces in so d3 and now h6 we have
knight beat to d2 and knight to f6 uh
and here of course striking in the
center with c4 uh where it seems like um
uh you you maybe could capture this pawn
but as you know you never capture away
from the center you should always
capture towards the center unless um
that's exactly what you shouldn't do uh
but here it it simply wouldn't make any
sense because you would simply improve
white's central pawn structure so here
of course just c6 strengthening your own
central pawn structure and g3 now
preparing to find keto the other bishop
as well uh so very uh hyper modern
approach uh in this game against magnus
bishop to e7 and bishop the g2 we have
castles castles and not b to d7 uh we
have a3 preparing to grab more space on
the queen side with b4 and magnus of
course stops this he plays a5 and now
now this is uh although some of the
moves were somewhat rare we've
transposed to a pretty standard position
and now usually people play queen to c2
here you connect the rooks this way or
even rook to a2 is an idea this was also
very popular where you could shift your
queen over to a1 and then
try and do a lot of damage using this
diagonal but rapper tries something uh
completely different he plays queen to
b1 it's not completely different it's
still uh you know uh has the same ideas
in mind uh but now after carlson's
bishop to h7 uh rihard goes for b4 uh
there are a couple of games or rather
three other games where bishop the c3
was played pretty much with the same
idea of playing bishop c3 queen to b2
and grabbing hold of this diagonal but
that upward goes b for now and it's uh
well it's a very interesting
as uh
uh wha what can what can magnus do here
well magnus plays okay a captures on b4
it this is not a first capture you could
also just ignore it and the game just
continues the other rook will come to c1
the bishop will come to c3
queen to b2 and so on but magnus decides
to trade he plays captures captures and
now queen to b6 he puts pressure on the
b6 pawn but rapper just defends it with
bishop to c3 but now this is the fun
part the bishop and queen are guarding
the b4 pawn and the bishop and queen are
attacking the b4 pawn however you could
eliminate one of the defenders of the
pawn by playing rook captures on a1 the
queen would move and then you can
capture on b4
so this is exactly what happens in the
game magnus captures on a1 we have queen
captures and now bishop captures on b4
and you can't uh attack the bishop with
rook to b1 because we're just going to
capture on c3 and now attack white's
queen also and after let's say queen
captures on c3 we can just go back at
the end of this a very nice line black
is up a pawn so instead after the ship
captures on b4 rapper recaptures and now
queen captures on b4 but now comes rook
to b1 and now as the queen has to move
we are going to recapture with real
captures on b7 and okay this is what
magnus wanted queen to d6 we have rook
captures on b7 and now uh e5 magnus says
all right you have a active rook on b7
but what is it even really doing there i
have a beautiful center here so what's
your counter play uh well at upward
place d4 and now what can magnus play
here the problem is if you grab more
space with e4 then we can put our knight
on e5 the queen on a1 nicely controls
the e5 square so black can never really
capture the knight if you capture them
we just capture back and then black
loses a piece so that's not happening so
after d4 magnus plays e captures on d4
and now we have knight captures on d4
and now uh again magnus continues in a
very interesting fashion at pawn to c5
and now uh should the knight move maybe
we can grab more space with the d4 uh
however if you play knight to b5 for
example we can just play queen e6 and
now yes you are attacking the d5 pawn
but magnus will be attacking the e2 pawn
and now after you defend this then
magnus can even play something like d
captures on c for now the opponent c4 is
defended and uh okay it's a double uh
past c pawn but it's still a double path
seep on that magnus is controlling so i
should be very scary so robert instead
goes knight for back to b3 and now
magnus advances the pawn all the way to
d4 so now we have bishop to h3 putting
pressure on this knight here so the
knight on f6 can never move
and magnus has to decide how to continue
this position there are many ways to
continue this many good ways many uh
well bad ways uh one thing is that you
could go for rook to b8 you could trade
off um
the rooks because your rook isn't doing
all that much on f8 whereas rapport's to
rook is incredibly active on b7 another
thing you could do is just play g5 also
very nice as now look at this your pawn
is controlling e3 this one controlling
f4 it's very unlikely that white will be
able to push any pawns here and you will
have just a very interesting game we
might go into something like bishop
captures on d7 knight captures and queen
to a5 putting more pressure on the c5
pawn but black can just play a rook to
c8 and everything uh is perfectly fine
so this is uh these are only some of the
options however magnus plays d3 he
advances the pawn here and he says all
right you either capture here then i
capture back and i've ruined your
structure a little bit plus i have a an
incredibly active queen or you advance
the pawn and then i have a pass pawn on
d3 but this is exactly what that upper
does interestingly you could also
advance it all the way to e4 the knight
here isn't really attacking the four
pawn the knight has to be guarding the
the d7 knight because the bishop and
rook are both attacking it so okay e4 is
possible rapport decides to play e3 and
now we have knight to e5 as by playing
e3 the f3 square was weakened now the
knight can come to f3 if the knight from
d2 ever moves could be very dangerous so
here at bishop back to g2 we need to uh
well uh
get a better control of the f3 square
and now the position is incredibly
dangerous and for several reasons magnus
should move the knight back but uh
that's only for uh for those of you who
are interested in pausing the video
after i show you what magnus actually
played so here magnus played rook the c8
he added another defender to the c5 pawn
and now the position is winning for
rapport uh incredible as it seems but if
you uh take into consideration what i
what i said
about what magnus should have played you
should have an easier time deciding on
what to play here so feel free to pause
the video and try to win this game for
rapport while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well uh spectacular idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is pawn to f4 that's why you should
have moved the knight because this way
you allow the f4 pawn to be pushed with
tempo neither knight has to move and
then you have e4 another incredibly
threatening move as then e5 is being
threatened and this will just be
overwhelming for black so magnus goes
knight e to g4
it doesn't matter if you go back to c6
or or wherever it's um the same plan for
white so rapport just plays e4 and now
how do you how do you stop white uh you
you can uh remember that we mentioned
that the pawn on d4 controlled e3 and if
magnus played the g5 controlling f4
white will pretty much be uh
uh unable uh to push any of the pawns
but now without doing so without pushing
g5 and with over pushing the the pawn on
d3 he actually allowed this beautiful
expansion for rapport which is now
causing him a lot of problems so the
idea is how do you stop
a move like e5 let's say you play queen
e6 you move the queen now comes queen to
a7 and again what can black play let's
say you play something you play rook to
e8 now comes rook to b6 you harass the
black queen and after queen to c8 you
can play e5 and now the bishop again
comes alive it's just a very very
difficult position to play for black
also you've taken away the f6 square
from black's pieces so you're also going
to have to worry about h3 at some point
so let's say knight to d7 we play rook
to c6 chase the chase the queen away and
once the queen moves let's say 28 rook
to d6 we're gonna put pressure on the
knight once black defends this now comes
h3 and where can the knight go
there is but one square that is knight
to e3 but now the queen can pick up the
knight if the c5 pawn moves so now we're
just going to capture on c5 and now we
are adding a third attacker to the d7
knight and also after this knight moves
the e3 knight will be uh in in a lot of
trouble so there is really not all that
much you can do here you can add another
defender for example to the knight uh
and now we just go for for trading
everything captures captures captures
captures captures captures and of course
not capturing the queen but queen
captures knight on e3 uh white is up a
piece and completely winning so this
this is only something that can happen
i'm just showing you what a powerful
idea this
f4 e4 idea is and how difficult it is
for magnus to tackle this so you have to
give up something the question is what
will you give up well magnus says all
right i invite your e5 move in and i'm
going to give up my knight for two two
pawns which is not all that bad i
eliminated these two pawns i i still
have a passport on d3 so i should
definitely have chances here uh well
let's see e5 uh knight captures on e5 we
have f captures on e5 and rook captures
an e5 so it looks uh very dangerous for
airport as well however uh here a rapper
just plays rook to b6 he says all right
you can capture my rook but if you play
that i'm gonna capture your rook and
here
black will not have all that much
control play we're still up a piece and
not all that much for black to do so
magnus instead plays queen to e7 now
threatening queen to e1 check to pick up
robert's queen but now comes rook to b8
with check we have knight to e8 and now
comes bishop to c6 here he attacks the
knight threatens rook captures an e8 and
he even allows rook to e1 but um
if you don't play rook to e1 there is
really not all that much to play because
after rook captures on e8 is just all
over so magnus plays rook to e1 and now
what do you play here well of course you
know as we've reached the position from
the thumbnail uh rapport simply picks up
the rook queen captures on e1 we can
even see that uh once more in in super
slow motion there we go as i know how
much you guys enjoy this uh a queen
captures an e1 and now there's really
not all that much uh
for magnus to do uh because if he uh if
rapper should block with for example
knight to f1 then queen e3 check and you
quickly get checkmated king g2 queen e2
checking h3 bishop f5 check and after
the king moves even g5 checkmate is
possible uh or if you try after rook to
e1 you don't have to block you can play
king to g2 it's still a very nice king
hunt we're just going to go queen to a
to check again this bishop to f uh fight
with checking h4 now even queen captures
an h2 can be checkmate so of course
while this is all very nice that upper
goes for the absolute the best and only
move and that is queen capture sunny one
magnus captured on e1 with check so uh
let's not forget this is with check but
rapper just plays knight to f1 and he
was in this position on move 33 that
magnus cause and resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh to give you an example let's say you
try d2 uh point being that if maybe rook
captures we can capture with the queen
and then bring another queen into gamer
up or just picks up the pawn and there
is really nothing here for black and
another thing that pretty much the only
thing left for you to do is kink to f8
maybe try and play this end game uh this
is also impossible it operates very
happily trades here captures captures
characters and captures and now knight
captures on c5 and now uh okay we just
have to win the d3 pawn and that's it
let's say king e7 we're going to play
king f2 king to d6 knight goes back now
you can see the pawn and knight are
completely cutting off the black king
and well there's really not all that
much after you play this king e3 is
coming next we're going to attack the d3
pawn with one of our knights and it's
game over
so of course after knight to f1 magnus
resigned the game and what a spectacular
victory for rihar rapport in round eight
of the 2017 tata still chess tournament
and he didn't do all that great in the
tournament but he managed to ruin the
tournament for magnus which is also very
very impressive so if you guys are
interested uh these are the standings of
the 2017 tata still chess tournament you
can see that
the winner was wesley so
one full point ahead of magnus carlsen
uh had magnus uh
won this game against against rapport
then we would have tie breaks and they
would go into a playoff this way wesley
wins it clear and rapport definitely
ruined the day a little bit for magnus
but he also
uh well just played a very very
spectacular game uh finding all of this
with queen capture sunny one uh queen
captures an e1 is not a difficult move
to find it's a difficult move to find
all the way where upwards so it probably
uh ten moves ago
uh but yeah you can see that wesley one
magnus second place uh
arunyan and wei yi tied with seven and a
half uh karayaki nandalano with seven
agiri with six and a half hari
and andreikin with six and uh watashi
with six uh nepo with five rapport with
four and a half and lokhan valley with
three and a half so as you can see not a
spectacular tournament but he was still
very young this was uh 2017 and you can
see that uh how far
he got now he is this close to reaching
the candidates tournament and of course
if he wins that uh then he will also get
his chance to challenge magnus carlsen
once again but now not just for a
beautiful game but also maybe even for
the title it's still a long way to go of
course we'll see what happens in the in
the third leg of the grand prix and of
course then the candidates tournament
but it's always nice to theorize a
little bit like that
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it for those of you who haven't
seen it i'm sure it's uh uh you guys are
very impressed but even those of you who
were following
the chess scene back in 2017 i think uh
it's a nice game to revisit so yeah once
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank um uh max swarovski
francis air jeffrey menser abdul rahman
al-mari in the drawer almost for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon by continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day